ja es ist wenn man darüber nachdenkt
wirklich ärgerlich wie viele meldungen
jetzt schon wieder untergehen wegen
corona ja das ist eine weltweite krise
diese pandemie aber deswegen werden ja
nicht alle anderen themen unwichtig über
manches was gerade politisch unter dem
radar läuft hätte man es noch vor wochen
alle furchtbar aufgeregt sehr schade
wirklich denn für manche leute ist
aufregend ja das liebste hobby
[Musik]
hassknecht hobbythek wir basteln uns
noch mehr politikverdrossenheit liebe
bastelfreunde noch mehr
politikverdrossenheit geht das überhaupt
klar
zum beispiel indem man den bundestag
immer weiter aufbläht jetzt schon
zweitgrößtes parlament der welt nach
china
aber sah es noch luft nach oben sei
einzig jahren reg ich mich da schon
drüber auf in dieser show
ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie oft schon
immer wieder wahlrechtsreform
gebetsmühlenartig gebrauchen eine
wahlrechtsreform
jetzt hat der bundestag tatsächlich eine
verabschiedet toll
kleiner haken das ist überhaupt keine
selige drei überhangmandate werden nicht
mehr ausgeglichen absender der rest die
super kompliziert einfach mal googeln
hat ist aktuell haben wir 7 109
parlamentarier ja das sollten weniger
werden experten haben anhand aktueller
umfragen aber ausgerechnet wenn jetzt
wahl wäre könnte uns diese reform
missgeburt bis zu 750 abgeordnete
bescheren
fällt ihnen das auf 760 ist gar nichts
weniger als 700 9
das ist sogar mehr und das
allerschlimmste
am ende könnte ausgerechnet die elende
csu mehr mandate kriegen als ihr nach
zweitstimmen zusteht verfassungswidrig
was sagt man dazu
aber ich glaube das ist jetzt ein
kompromiss der kann sich sehen lassen
und er ist eben und das ist wichtig für
velen willst du denn so und nächste
woche bei wir basteln uns
politikverdrossenheit die bundeswehr
blamiert sich weiter unsere soldaten
kriegen doch kein neues sturmgewehr
müssen jetzt die alten weiterbenutzt
hilft ja nix
ja und der auftrag für den neuen
transport hubschrauber ist komplett
gestoppt
zur erheiterung hier nochmal eine fast
schon schmerzhaft schöne metapher und
entscheiden für die männer und frauen
ist was hinten raus kommt und das ist
ein neuer schwerer transporthubschrauber
so muss es sein
da lacht der podologe ja it-service
bruns weiß ich spreche mit jürgen wie
kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
ja haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus
und wieder einzuschalten hat nichts
gebracht verstehe ja probieren sie doch
mal den kanal der heute show auf youtube
zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel ruhig auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung